[Music]
so so many Christians are in darkness
practicing yoga without understanding
the ancient secrets of Eastern knowledge
with the cunning marketing tactics of
Hindu influencers yoga has become
synonymous with stretching exercise and
meditation Our Guest Ivan Raj is the
creator of yoga unboxed a series to help
debunk yoga as a benign practice we
welcome Ivan Raj back to a wolf in
sheep's clothing thank you so much for
being here my pleasure in part one of
this series between you and I you
described your background can you give
it to us again just so the people who
weren't here could could get it
absolutely so I was actually raised in a
Christian household although I was uh I
know I studied in a Hindu school and
that exposed me to Hinduism and yoga so
yoga unboxed give us some in-depth
insight into what this is really about
okay so yoga unboxed is a a series of U
videos
it's like a documentary style
documentary SL talk style set of videos
and U it is designed for the ex
Christian the Western exchristian who
has abandoned Christianity and embraced
Hinduism through yoga to reconsider
Christianity in part one you discussed
how you were Christian and then in your
research to try to understand more about
Hind Hinduism and about yoga that you
actually became converted just by what
you were beholding yes uh I did uh get
influenced just by researching as you
said just by beholding uh on uh
basically just researching on yoga it
actually influenced me to shun
Christianity shun Christ shun the Bible
and consider Hinduism as my way of life
so you're helping people in Ence skip
that without being induced and Indo ated
a new you're giving them the direct shot
correct exactly direct shot is right
okay so where would you like to start
with this with regards to yoga unboxed
okay so with regards to yoga unboxed
um so so the first five episodes of yoga
unbox is about the origins of
yoga so when we look into the origins of
yoga and when we look into Genesis 3:
1-7 they're one and the same but but the
villain so to speak in the Bible or
villain in the Bible is the hero here MH
okay uh like for example in Genesis
chapter 3 vers 1- 7 verses 1-
7 so there is a garden right Garden of
Eden in the East uh uh uh uh Bible tells
us in the East God planted
the tree of knowledge of Good and Evil
so when we look into Hinduism which is
from the East uh you have the teachings
that a human can be divine and the human
will be
reincarnated reborn so in other words
you will not surely die why because you
are actually God so it's a different
iteration and translation of what we
believe in the Bible yes and uh the and
God said you will not sorry God
commanded Adam and Eve that they should
not eat from the Tree of knowledge of
Good and Evil God commanded whereas in
Hinduism it is a way of life eat as much
as you like partake in it follow your
heart follow your heart exactly follow
do what thou Wilt follow your heart so
that's the teaching and then uh in um in
in the Bible a serpent talks to the
woman and the serpent tells the woman uh
the teachings that you will not surely
die you will become Gods right and when
you look into Hindu writings it says
that a serpent took the form of a human
being and he was called as paneli and uh
probably you might have heard yes in my
training they told us about patanjali
patanjali yes so patanjali according to
yogic lore or according to yogic
writings or the origins of yoga pangali
was a ancient wise serpent he is called
as adha sesha means serpent ADI means
ancient he's also called as ananta sesha
ananta means wise so ancient wise
serpent was the one who took the form of
a human being and he's called as pangel
and he was the one who wrote all of the
aphorisms of the wise sayings of yoga so
in other words the serpent according to
Hinduism or yogic teachings the the
ancient wise serpent who became pangali
wrote the principles of yoga all Yoga
practices doesn't matter whether
stretching or meditation all of these
are influenced and and uh and they're
derived from patanjali's 195 wise
sayings of yoga are called yoga sutras
are these the
UTS uh no no opit are different are
different yeah opit and vas those are
different okay yeah bhag Gita that's all
different this is different okay so we
see that patang is being used as almost
a God in and of himself correct giving
his own Commandments and instead of
there being 10 there's 195 you yeah some
people say most of them say 195 some of
them say 165 uh but interestingly they
say that uh his place of birth uh is not
known it's EXA precise place place of
birth is not known some believe he was
born in South born in South India uh
some people believe he was born in North
India regardless whatever he
wrote um according to Hinduism it fits
in one page there are four chapters in
what he wrote like the yoga sutras they
have four chapters and the second
chapter has eight limbs of yoga in the
eight limbs of yoga one of the limb is
the
posture which is what has been brought
to the US and basically said we're
calling it exercise yes it is brought
into the us as a form of exercise for
physical fitness and stretching and so
forth and uh This Is Not A New Concept
perhaps uh for the West it might be a
New Concept uh in terms of physical
expression of worship and uh these uh
these type of physical expression of
worship such things have been existing
since ancient times even yoga also uh
especially the stretching Parts many
gurus say that uh it's been existing
only for the last 500 years but before
that yoga was purely
meditation and for a person to meditate
for many hours stretching was introduced
and the stretching has meaning the
posture SL stretching they have meaning
to it they have meanings to it and that
being said we also can see that such uh
physical expression of worship existed
even in Bible times even the Old
Testament times I would like to show a
scripture from Ezekiel chapter 8 and uh
we can read from Ezekiel chapter 8
[Music]
and Ezekiel
8:15 says then he said to me that is God
speaking to Prophet Ezekiel here have
you seen this oh son of man turn again
you will see greater Abominations than
these so God tells the prophet Ezekiel
that he's going to show Ezekiel greater
Abominations what is that what are those
greater Abominations let's see in verse
16 so he brought me
into the inner Court of the Lord's house
and there at the door of the Temple of
the Lord between the porch and the altar
were about 25 men with their backs
toward the Temple of the Lord and their
faces toward the East and they were
worshiping the son Su
n scripture tells us that they were
worshipping the sun toward the East now
when we look into the Lexicon the root
word or the ual word for
worshiping is to
prostrate right to FL just flatten
yourself on the ground to Bow before
they were bowing before the sun now they
did not chant
mantras uh but all they did was Express
their Devotion to Su son God suryya
namaskara Sun salutation with their
posture and God said that was the
greatest Abomination Abomination and
they did that as quote unquote believers
inside the Temple of the Lord so as
Christians we have to realize that the
author and finisher of our faith is
Jesus Christ and whatever God has
prescribed to us in the Bible for our
longevity for our health we should
practice it rather than
adopting customs and rituals from other
religions so in the first part of our
conversation we talked about identifying
whether this was yoga was just exercise
whether it was benign and we covered the
fact that it's not it's actually a
rooted in spiritualism can you take us
to some examples that prove your point
that yoga is rooted in spiritualism
absolutely because uh again yoga teaches
that a person will be reincarnated right
and the person is a God or a goddess
within and in order to extract the
Divinity you have yoga or Hinduism says
practice yoga and again yoga is
atheistic in nature and um so yoga is a
practical part the Practical uh School
of another uh uh School of Hinduism
called Samia Samia philosophy samya
means numbers so it is theory part and
yoga is the Practical part so in yoga it
is uh all about you know nature worship
pantheism and you are part of the nature
and as you keep on doing it as you keep
as a person keeps on doing yoga practice
then it becomes a spiritual posture now
I'm not saying this uh there was um a
guru called bks AAR familiar with him
when I was in India it was one of the
things that I had to study AAR yoga yes
AAR yoga yes so he said and it's on
video it's on YouTube anybody can go to
YouTube and look for b k s iar y e n g j
a r I believe or um y n j a
AAR BK AAR said um initially the
postures and the stretching are physical
but as they keep on doing it it becomes
a spiritual posture and it transforms
the person right and this is why we
can't have Christians doing it because
it CH it LS them yes it changes it
changes that is one and then meditation
right so that points to that that leads
people slowly but surely without their
knowledge it'll lead them into Hindu ISM
through yoga meditation and therefore
atheism therefore atheism yes I am my
own God that it's called the term is
called aham brahmasmi aham means I
brahmasmi means god aham brahmasmi in
fact many Hindus even chant those words
aham Brasi bras because they believe as
they keep on chanting it it is to remind
themselves that I am God aham brahmasmi
so yoga leads the person away from
Christ salvation it separates the person
from Christ into another deity and get
connected to another deity's mind and
that deity is Shiva now Shiva is the
word a certain Guru teaches that uh
Shiva the word Shiva means that which is
not that which is not now when we look
into the Bible and let's say we ask Eve
hey Eve in the Garden of Eden did you
see Satan her response would be no he
was not right he showed up as a serpent
he showed up as a serpent but she didn't
see him correct he was not uh he entered
The Serpent and the serpent spoke to her
and um so in in
Hinduism Shiva is under uh Shiva is
Shiva is manifested in different forms
avatars so the word Avatar means
uh descended in other words Fallen also
and um we actually have a picture that
uh we can show to our audience alien
picture um and in that image of the
alien uh you can see that um you know
Shiva is called as yaka swarupa which is
actually a um a Sanskrit word yaka means
foreign or alien not belonging to the
human race swarupa means form and and um
it is taught that uh Shiva is also an
alien and uh and he did not come here
alone he came with a group of his
friends to this Earth from elsewhere
thousands of years ago this reminds me
of Revelation it says that there a war
broke out in heaven and that a third of
the Angels were were wiped out and this
sounds like an omission of guilt so one
third of the Angels came down here to
Earth says the Bible and interestingly
Hinduism says that Shiva came down to
earth he descended they don't say Fallen
they say descended so the word Avatar
means descended there are various forms
of Shiva and Avatar is a Sanskrit word
and there are various forms of Shiva and
one of the forms is yaka swarupa which
we were just looking at and uh there's
also a couple of other forms that we can
uh we can show a couple of pictures now
because like hundreds of forms of Shiva
let's go to the next picture and uh here
Shiva is in the form of ardhanarishwara
also a Sanskrit word and um it looks
like it's a half woman and half man
correct half male and half uh female yes
half woman half man and he also has a
trident interestingly in many of the
cartoon movies they show you know wasn't
it Zeus as well had a trident yeah yeah
the Trident and we see the same in in uh
in Shiva also that he's also holding a
trident and uh so in this form um so he
according to Hindu teachings um that he
became one with um his um the lady that
he taught yoga is that Eve in the script
we can say yes it is Eve um according to
the scriptures but in Hinduism the first
yoga student was a woman so after she
learned yoga from um Shiva she became
one with him in other words she yoked
with him she yoga with him because as we
know you know it I'm sure the word yoga
comes from a root word called yug y u j
which means to yoke to bind and
interestingly the word religion also
means the same uh religion the word
religion in English is from a Latin word
called religio which also means to bind
to link to connect so whether it is yog
or the word religion they both are one
in the same to bind to connect to uh to
become one so uh here Parvati is a name
of this this woman and Parvati became
one with Shiva and also uh when it comes
to gender and all those things right
Hinduism does not have male and female
genders anybody can look it up on Google
and if you look up on Google how many
genders are there in Hinduism you will
find the answer male female others
others other gender so Shiva is neither
male nor female he's he's no thing some
people say it's very confusing because
in in
Christianity uh there's a point a the
point a is we as humans are all sinners
point B is you get to heaven to be with
your lord and savior for eternity so how
to get from point A to point B
that is laid out as a Plan of Salvation
in the Bible but in Hinduism that
doesn't exist there's no point a point B
because it's like a rabbit hole you keep
circling circling around and known as
karma and reincarnation yes even even uh
before a person dies if people want to
do a research there's a lot of lot of
rituals involved in a proper Hinduism
even in yogic Hinduism also there's a
lot of chanting involved there's a lot
of stretching involved which is a
physical expression of worship so I want
to go back to Shiva the the source of
yoga and by the way Shiva is the source
of yoga and Shiva uh spoke to the
serpent who became uh pangali and he
wrote the principles of yoga which the
whole world is practicing today and uh
so Shiva uh taught the secrets of yoga
to a woman and they became one and
therefore ad adishwar and and uh we can
also look at the next form of Shiva on
screen and this is a very very popular
uh picture or a statue of Shiva it's
called the
nataraja posture or sorry nataraja form
of Shiva NATA means dance drama acting
so he Lord of the Dance exactly Lord of
the Dance drama acting so that is Shiva
and if you look at the feet of that PCT
at the picture in that picture if you
look at his feet he actually crushing a
male child now some Hindus say it is not
a child it's a dwarf of
ignorance and some Hindus say it is a
male child it basically the upside down
of the curse that God gave to the
serpent in Genesis in Genesis exactly so
it's the upside down and this is
nataraja p um uh nataraja uh statue the
picture that we just showed and it is
found in almost all of the Indian
restaurants around the world and it
represents the uh according to Hinduism
so-called dominance of uh Shiva over
ignorance and there's also a serpent
even in that uh even in that picture
also so we see the presence of the
serpent repeated it's just you know
Amplified you see it around shiva's neck
you you see it in the actual poses that
you do bujang gasana basana you know or
Cobra pose and it's usually right out of
the transition from a plank you know a
push-up position and then you are
raising your heart up and this is an
homage right this is this is worship yes
so we as Christians shouldn't be
engaging in this in any form absolutely
we should not engage in any form of
physical expression of worship and let's
remember again Ezekiel chapter 8 we we
saw verse 15 and 16 that it was the
greatest Abomination H doing Sun worship
without even chanting I also want to
read another scripture from Matthew and
we can show it on the screen from
Matthew and
uh Matthew chap 4 verse
8910 Matthew 4: 8-10 again the devil
took him up to an exceedingly high
mountain that is devil took Jesus to an
exceedingly high mountain and showed him
all the kingdoms of the world and their
Glory verse n and he said to Jesus all
these things I will give you
if you fall down and worship
me here uh here the devil doesn't tell
Jesus light a candle for me sing a song
for me you know all he says is bow down
before just your posture exactly just
your posture is enough for me mhm and he
says if you do that I'll give you all
the glory of this world now we see that
if anyone you know becomes a yoga
teacher generally speaking you make a
lot lot of money very quickly I did
indeed see so any any yoga teacher would
say that because people build their um
you know their their lives on it on this
business well you become a guru to other
people you're a God you know that
promise that lie that he tells you you
know worship me and I'll give you truth
that that ends up being manifested I I
became an instructor I was at all the
the primary clubs and people really
trusted me with their lives they would
confess things to me it was very
interesting right so people do trust you
some people might have even bowed down
to you uh by saying Namaste because
Namaste the word Namaste means the
Divine In Me bows to the Divine in you
that is
Namaste and uh so yeah so people would
have said Namaste to you you would have
said Namaste to your students so this is
a very common practice and you also
asked me I think uh earlier you asked me
about Christianity and Hinduism right
another difference I'll share at this
point uh you mentioned about
gurus so in yoga there is a concept
called not only in yoga even in martial
arts so anything that comes from
Hinduism or Eastern ancient Eastern
practice all of ancient Eastern
practices their roots are found in
Hinduism from India okay and I love my
country I I love India it's beautiful
country I most of my friends are Hindus
okay so that being said uh Guru parara
is a concept meaning lineage of gurus so
in martial arts or in yoga or anything
that comes from Hinduism right so what
is important is who is your Guru who is
your guru's Guru so it's called gurus
lineage of
gurus Guru parara so if a proper uh
devout Hindu wants to learn let's say a
Hindu dance called badanam or martial
arts or yoga they will look up who was
your Guru who was your guru's Guru the
reason I'm sharing this is because as
you keep on tracing guru's guru guru's
guru guru's guru you end up with Shiva
as the AI Guru meaning the ancient
teacher in the
Bible who is your father what's your
father's name right and you go back all
the way to to Adam geny is there and
then Jesus yes so these two are separate
paths one is Guru par leads you to Shiva
the other one which is from the Bible it
leads you to Jesus Christ it's
interesting you say that because when I
did go and live in an Asam it there was
such an emphasis being placed on the
fact that I was being trained by Mahesh
the I guess
grandson of Mahesh who had trained The
Beatles oh okay okay I until this moment
it's like an aha moment I didn't realize
that I was being connected to that
lineage by receiving that instruction
the word mahes also means Shiva Maha Mah
Mah meaning is is ishwara which is
pointing to Shiva Maha means um great so
great Shiva so that is the meaning of
the name uh and the yogi you're
referring to uh who who coached or
trained Beatles uh I think his name is
uh Maharishi Mahesh Yogi or something
like exactly that is exactly who it is
yeah so so much importance is given to
who is your teacher who is your Guru and
not who is your dad so we're winding
down I just want you to emphasize again
what is the origin of yoga so the
origins of yoga is found in
Shiva Shiva so Hinduism teaches that
from within
Shiva yoga
originated and uh Hinduism also teaches
that he is the universe in the west it's
become very common these days I'm
talking to the universe I prayed to the
universe the universe brought us
together it conspires things to happen
for us yes say uh you know say positive
things put those positive words out and
the universe will make it happen so that
is Hinduism that points to Shiva as well
so we shouldn't be manifesting either as
Christians because we're taking up
idolatry yes we should pray and seek the
Lord's perfect will in our lives and the
Lord has told us to come to his throne
boldly and present our supplications to
him so we have a father we are we are
not orphans Jesus said I'm not going to
leave you as orphans we have a father a
Heavenly Father our Lord and Savior
Jesus Christ amen I just want to
conclude by saying that you know for all
our needs especially Health needs we
have our Lord and Savior Jesus Christ
the author and finisher of her faith and
also the longest living people the
strongest and longest living people
on this Earth are 7-Day Adventists who
do not practice yoga but they derive
their lifestyle from the word of God
there is no yoga Blue Zone there has
never been a yoga Blue Zone good point
very good point could you tell our
audience how they can find yoga unboxed
absolutely so yoga unboxed is found at
yoga unbox
docomo there and they can either rent
the videos or they can also make a
donation a tax riable donation if they
want to support our ministry it's yoga
unboxed decom and when you rent the
videos you're going to learn a lot of
information uh about Hinduism and the
origins of yoga in detail it's really
been an honor the things that you've
exposed are really in nature salvic had
I known that this was the truth I would
have never endeavored and I would have
not gone down this path so from the
bottom of my heart thank you for doing
this you're very welcome and we can't
wait to have you next
time as we have learned today yoga is
Hindu Worship in motion the philosophies
behind it are antithetical to Christian
doctrine within Hinduism all paths lead
to Enlightenment scripture tells us
Jesus is the way the yoga practitioner
makes void the legitimacy of Christ and
salvation through Christ as the author
and finisher of our faith by bowing down
to other gods we really need to take the
time to unbox yoga and thankfully Ivan
Raj has made all the work simple and
easy to access make sure to check it out
until next time see you on a wolf in
sheep's
[Music]
clothing
[Applause]
[Music]